it takes a week to build a plant like
this one
soon it will be ready to accommodate cow
manure and after two more weeks
these dairy farmers will have their own
supply of biogas the plant was a major
investment for the couple I wanted
because I have been using wood fair wood
chuckles guys do cows from here
tell Emily to give that money a German
NGO called atmosfair and its local
partner sustainable energy strategies
helped set up this biogas plant and 800
more across key ambu County near the
Kenyan capital Nairobi with such
facilities we can make use of the cow
dung that's produced every day in
gardens like this to generate clean
biogas and if there's no smoke in the
kitchen there are no co2 emissions
either
so each biogas plant means four tons
less co2 each year the biggest problem
for people here is finding the money to
pay for a plant the smallest model costs
300 euros that's too much for most
farming families who also have to pay
school fees for their children the
market is huge in this country but the
problem is a lot of people are not able
to afford so they don't have the money
to finance it even though we get a
subsidy from atmosphere
there are hundreds of smallholder farms
in qiyam boo
they grow maize cattle feed and
vegetables the yield is often just
enough to feed the families farming the
land so adding a biogas plant is a big
deal Phyllis when Bowie was able to
afford one she'd save some of the money
she makes with her six hundred
egg-laying hens and her cows and she was
able to guess a microloan the plant is
fed with manure mixed with water a pipe
under the ground takes the gas produced
to her kitchen natalia Toronado
I wanted a plant after I had seen one at
my neighbor's is so easy now I used to
have to gather firewood and go and buy
charcoal and it was very expensive now I
have no problems I come home late and
cook supper in ten minutes then you are
a cake amigo go to get AG Mulligan
runyan a byproduct of the biogas plant
is a nutritious ferment which can be
used as organic fertilizer to enhance
crop yields the farmers can use it
themselves or sell it sick obsession and
a themed video there is a system in
place for collecting produce from farms
but there's no certification here for
organically grown fruit and vegetables
it would be great if there were and if
growers could claim they use no chemical
fertilizers or pesticides
not some kind of person see double nuts
another problem facing farmers here is
that the rainy season is at least four
weeks late this year
they're worried that with the soil
parched their crops won't grow
these men are on their way to buy water
their well has dried up massive
deforestation has transformed the water
cycle the land is literally drying up
just since the year 2000 almost 10% of
Kenya's forests have been felled illegal
logging remains a major problem Phyllis
when bouys crops are not doing well
we're suffering because of the drought
we have to buy water now and it's very
expensive it's hard for us we need water
for our vegetables and our animals but
now that she has a biogas plant at least
she doesn't have to buy firewood anymore
frying eggs for the children after
school takes just a moment Phyllis will
have paid off her loan in one year's
time she doesn't regret the investment
in the slightest the biogas plant has
changed her life for the better
you